Dominica, de Pizzas Dominica,
hornea diariamente la misma cantidad de pizzas.
Ella gasta 8 pesos diarios usando el horno
y 1.50 en los ingredientes de cada pizza.
Un día, el precio de los ingredientes aumentó
de 1.50 a 2 pesos por pizza.
Dominica hizo algunas cuentas
y encontró que debería hornear 8 pizzas más al día
para que el precio
de la venta de sus pizzas quedara igual.
Escribe una ecuación para encontrar
el número de pizzas que hornea a diario
antes de que aumentó el precio.
Usa "p" para representar el número de pizzas.
Ok, vamos a ir sacando los datos de este problema,
así que vámonos con calma, dice,
Dominica, de Pizzas Dominica,
hornea diariamente la misma cantidad de pizzas.
Ok, y aquí hay un dato importante.
Hornea diariamente
la misma cantidad de pizzas, ok.
Ella gasta 8 pesos diarios...
8 pesos diarios, usando el horno,
y 1.50... y 1.50, en los ingredientes de
cada una de las pizzas, que hornea cada día.
Un día, aumentó los precios de
1.50 a 2 pesos por pizza.
Aumenta el precio de los ingredientes por pizza
y entonces Dominica hizo algunas cuentas
y encontró que debería hornear 8 pizzas más...
8 pizzas más al día,
para que el precio de venta
de sus pizzas quedara igual.
Y aquí,
hay una de las palabras claves de este problema,
quedara igual...
quedara igual.
Escribe una ecuación
para encontrar el número de pizzas
que horneaba a diario antes de que aumentó el precio.
Usa "p" para representar el número de pizzas,
muy bien.
Pues vamos vaciando,
la información que me da este problema.
Vamos a pensar primero,
qué es lo que pasa con Dominica
antes de que el precio aumente.
Entonces voy a poner aquí antes...
antes de que el precio aumente,
y después nos vamos a fijar en,
qué es lo que pasa con Dominica
después de que el precio aumente.
Antes de que el precio aumente,
¿qué es lo que gasta Dominica?
Bueno, ella va a gastar
8 pesos diarios usando el horno,
así que por día,
va a gastar 8 pesos usando el horno
y estos son de cajón.
Forzosamente diario, va a gastar 8 pesos
horneando la misma cantidad de pizzas.
Que por cierto, el precio de los ingredientes
de cada una de las pizzas es de 1.50,
así que si hornea "p",
"p" pizzas porque justo es lo que no sabemos,
"p" pizzas hornea,
antes de que aumente el precio
y ojo eso es muy importante.
Antes de que aumente el precio,
entonces por cada una de ellas va a pagar 1.50,
entonces a 8 pesos que se gasta diario
usando el horno, le voy a aumentar 1.50...
1.50 por la cantidad de pizzas
que hornee durante todo el día,
y para eso voy a denotarlo con "p",
"p" es la cantidad de pizzas que va a...
Ahora los ingredientes
de cada una de las pizzas vale 1.50,
y esto es lo que se gasta en total por día
y si a esto lo dividimos
entre la cantidad  de pizzas,
a esto lo voy a dividir entre la cantidad de pizzas,
que vende en ese día,
que por cierto, nosotros sabemos,
que es la cantidad que hornea diariamente,
es decir, "p",
si esto lo dividimos entre "p",
aquí estoy representando,
lo que cuesta cada una de las pizzas
en total, por día.
Estoy viendo cuánto se gasta en total,
esta Dominica y lo estoy dividiendo
entre la cantidad de pizzas, por lo tanto,
aquí estoy representando lo que cuesta en total
hacer cada una de las pizzas, ok.
Y ahora, si pensamos en qué es lo que va a pasar, después de que aumente el precio,
bueno, después de que aumente el precio
va a pasar algo importante.
La cantidad... primero quiero que te des cuenta
que ella va a seguir usando el horno
y por lo tanto,
va a gastar 8 pesos diarios usando el horno,
eso no va a cambiar, ok.
Hasta aquí vamos bien,
y después a esto le vamos a agregar...
le vamos a agregar, ok...
Y ahora cambia el precio, de los ingredientes por pizza, de 1.50 a 2 pesos,
por lo tanto,
en lugar de gastar 1.50 por la cantidad de pizzas,
va a gastar 2 pesos,
por la cantidad de pizzas que va a hornear,
después de que aumente el precio.
Y justo aquí, está lo más importante
de todo este problema,
no es la misma "p",
date cuenta que aquí dice que Dominica
hizo algunas cuentas
y encontró que debería hornear 8 pizzas más al día,
para que el precio de venta de sus pizzas quedará igual.
¡8 pizzas más!
Por lo tanto,
ahora no va a estar haciendo "p" pizzas,
va a estar trabajando,
va a estar horneando,
"p" más 8 pizzas, es decir,
que si yo quiero ver
cuánto se gasta en total Dominica,
bueno pues tengo los 8 pesos del horno,
más 2 pesos por cada una de las pizzas,
pero actualmente hace "p" más 8 pizzas,
"p" más 8 pizzas...
oh, espera, no más 18...
más 8 pizzas,
porque aumenta la cantidad de pizzas
que va a hacer Dominica.
Ok, y si a esto lo divido, entre la cantidad de pizzas
que hace actualmente, es decir,
después de que aumentó el precio,
que por cierto, nosotros ya sabemos que es "p" más 8,
si a esto lo divido, entre "p" más 8,
aquí estoy representando,
lo que cuesta en total,
hacer una de las pizzas
después de que aumenta el precio,
es decir,
ahora que los ingredientes por pizza valen 2 pesos.
Y bueno, nosotros sabemos que hace 8 pizzas más,
eso es importante.
Ahora,
hasta aquí creo que vamos todo bien, sin embargo,
quiero hacer notar que viene otras partes
más importantes de todo este problema.
Si nosotros analizamos esta oración
con mucho cuidado,
entonces vamos a poder encontrar,
justo la ecuación que estamos buscando,
y vamos a poder resolver para "p".
Si te das cuenta,
dice que Dominica hizo algunas cuentas
y encontró
que debería hornear 8 pizzas más al día,
aquí ya lo pusimos,
para que el precio de venta de sus pizzas, quedara igual,
y eso es muy importante.
Si queremos
que el precio de venta de sus pizzas quede igual,
entonces lo que cuesta hacer cada una de sus pizzas,
antes de que aumente el precio,
debe de ser exactamente igual,
debe de ser exactamente igual
a lo que cuesta hacer cada una de sus pizzas,
después de que aumente el precio
de los ingredientes.
Esta parte que dice,
que el precio de venta de sus pizzas quedará igual,
lo que significa es que estas
dos expresiones matemáticas,
deben de ser iguales,
y si son iguales ya tenemos una ecuación,
que podemos resolver para "p",
si te das cuenta solamente tengo una incógnita,
que es "p"
así que qué te parece si nos ponemos las pilas
y vamos a resolver...
y vamos a resolver esta ecuación que tengo aquí.
Y bueno, para esto, si te das cuenta aquí tengo
dos expresiones que representan fracciones,
y a mí no me gusta trabajar con fracciones.
Así que para eso, voy a multiplicar toda,
toda esta ecuación, por los dos denominadores,
es decir, voy a multiplicar...
y déjenme mover un poco para acá la pantalla...
para acá la pantalla...
voy a multiplicar esta parte por "p",
ok, para eliminar esta "p",
pero también voy a multiplicar
por "p" más 8...
"p" más 8...
para que de este lado,
cuando yo multiplique por "p"
y después por "p" más 8...
por "p" más 8...
voy a eliminar, así, este otro denominador,
entonces voy a multiplicar de ambos lados por "p"
que multiplica a "p" más 8,
y esto para que podamos eliminar
los denominadores que nos estorban aquí.
Cuando nosotros tenemos fracciones, recuerda que a mí no me gusta trabajar mucho con fracciones.
Prefiero tener una ecuación que se vea un poco más amigable, así que vamos a eliminar esta "p" con esta "p",
y aquí me quedaría... bueno, pues me va a quedar,
"p" más 8... "p" más 8...
que multiplica...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
que multiplica a 8 más 1.50 por "p".
Esto del lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
mientras que del lado derecho,
me va a quedar que este
"p" más 8 con este "p" más 8 se va,
y solamente me queda "p",
que multiplica...
y déjame cambiar de color,
vamos a ponerlo con este color de aquí...
que multiplica a 8 más 2,
que a su vez multiplica a "p" más 8,
y es más vamos a hacerlo de una vez.
Si yo multiplico éste de aquí,
este 2 por "p" más 8
me va a quedar 2 que multiplica "p"
y 2 que multiplica 8,
es decir 8 más "2p"
más...
más 16...
Ok, de lujo,
así que ya tengo esta expresión de aquí,
y si te das cuenta, lo único que tengo
es una multiplicación algebraica, así que,
bueno, pues vamos a hacerla.
Voy a multiplicar esta "p", por éste,
y esta "p" por éste y me va a quedar,
"p" por 8 es "8p",
"8p" más "p" por "1.50p",
bueno estos "1.50p" cuadrada, ok,
y después hay que multiplicar,
éste por éste,
y éste por éste,
y me va a quedar 8 por 8 = 64, ok,
y 8 por 1.50, es lo mismo que 3 por 4,
lo cual es 12,
más "12p", ok,
esto tiene que ser exactamente igual,
esto tiene que ser igual
y bueno, voy a multiplicar
ahora de este otro lado de la ecuación ,
y me va a quedar "8p"
"8p" más"p" por "2p" es "16p" cuadrada, ok,
más "16p"...
más "16p", de lujo...
lo único que hice fue multiplicar
por los dos denominadores, para que se fueran,
y así, tener multiplicaciones algebraicas
muy fáciles de hacer.
Ahora, si te das cuenta acá abajo tenemos
una ecuación cuadrática, así que vamos a resolverla,
para esto voy a bajar la pantalla...
bajemos, bajemos, bajemos, la pantalla
para poder trabajar mejor lo que falta del problema
y ¡wow!
aquí tengo un "8p" y un "8p",
"8p" de un lado izquierdo y "8p" de un lado derecho,
se pueden ir,
es decir,
si yo restó "8p" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
este se va y este también se va,
entonces me va a quedar que tengo
"1.50p" cuadrada más 64 más "12p"
esto es igual a "16p" cuadrada más "16p".
Sin embargo,
aquí tengo una ecuación cuadrática,
así que qué te parece si mejor ponemos
todos los términos de un lado de la ecuación,
para poderla resolver
de una manera mucho más sencilla.
Y entonces me va a quedar a...
déjame poner primero la parte izquierda,
tengo 1.50 por "p" cuadrada,
ok, después voy a poner éste,
más 12 "p", ok, más 64,
esto tiene que ser igual,
y ahora voy a poner la parte izquierda que me queda,
"16p" cuadrada...
no, no, no, no,
aquí debe de haber algo raro
"16p" cuadrada es muchísimo,
a ver, ¿qué hice?
"p" por 8 = "8p"
"p" por "2p"...
claro, claro, claro, ¡aquí está mi error!
aquí no es "16p" cuadrada,
aquí es "2p" cuadrada.
Te das cuenta, lo que hice fue multiplicar por 8,
quién sabe porque...
aquí es "2p" cuadrada,
perdón, fue un error
que nos iba a traer muchos problemas después,
es decir, que del lado derecho tengo "2p" cuadrada
más "16p", ok, de lujo,
yo creo que me confundí con este "16p",
pero bueno, fue un error
que podemos corregir de una manera muy rápida.
Entonces, ahora lo que voy a hacer es restar
de este lado "2p" cuadrada, para que éstos se vayan,
y "16p" cuadrada, para que esto se vaya también,
y nos quede igual a 0,
pero lo que voy a hacer del lado izquierdo,
lo voy a hacer exactamente igual del lado derecho,
es decir, que aquí me va a quedar "-2p" cuadrada,
y aquí menos "16p", ok,
y ahora sí, si nosotros sumamos
estas dos expresiones que tengo aquí,
esta de aquí y esta de acá,
entonces me va a quedar, de este lado éste
y éste se va,
éste y éste se va
y del lado izquierdo me queda "1.50p" cuadrada,
menos "2p" cuadrada,
bueno, si tengo 1.50 pesos menos 2 pesos
me queda menos... "-0.5p" cuadrada, ok,
Ok, aquí tengo "12p" menos "16p"
esto es lo mismo que "-4p",
ok y aquí abajo es 64, más 64,
y esto es igual a 0.
Y es que es importantísimo tenerlo igual a 0,
porque aquí ya tengo una ecuación cuadrática,
la cual puede resolver de muchas maneras,
puedo utilizar fórmula general,
puedo factorizar,
puedo completar el binomio al cuadrado perfecto...
Vamos a resolverla.
Y bueno, para esto déjame bajar un poco la pantalla,
para terminar de resolver este problema.
A mí lo que me gusta mucho es factorizar,
así que para esto...
¡no puede factorizar desde aquí!
Lo que se me ocurre es multiplicar toda la ecuación,
por -2 para quitar este 0.5 que tengo aquí.
Entonces multiplicamos todo, todo, por -2....
-2, de tal manera,
que aquí me va a quedar solamente "p" cuadrada
menos por menos me da más,
2 por 0.5,
bueno eso es 1,
aquí me va a quedar "p" cuadrada
y después tengo -2 por -4,
esto es "8p"...
8p...
y después tengo -2 por 64, esto es -128...
-128,
esto tiene que ser igual a
0 por -2 lo cual es 0, de lujo,
y esta expresión ya es
mucho más amigable para factorizar
y justo eso es lo que voy a hacer ahorita,
voy a buscar dos números
que su producto sea -128,
su producto... producto...
que por cierto, date cuenta que uno
debe de ser positivo y el otro negativo,
y además que
cuando yo me tomé la suma de ambos,
la suma... me dé 8
la suma...
estoy buscando este par de números
y bueno se me ocurre, a ver,
128 y 1, no no no, estos no me sirven..
128... y si lo divido entre 2 me da 64,
2 y 64, no, tampoco me sirven ,
si tengo... si divido 128 entre... entre 8
¿cuánto me dan?
128 entre 8,
me cabe una vez, 1 por 8 es 8
y aquí le voy a restar 8,
y después aquí bajo un 4,
aquí hay un 8 y me queda 6 por 8 = 48
6... 16...
16 y 8...
¡Oh perfecto!
16 y 8 si me funcionan, fíjate bien,
128 lo puedo ver como,
16 positivo y 8 negativo, ok
16 por -8 me da -128
y después si yo a lo sumo
me queda 16 más -8
bueno eso es 16 menos 8 lo cual es 8.
De lujo, si me funciona,
es decir,
estoy diciendo que está expresión
cuadrática que tengo aquí,
es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme,
"p" más 16...
que a su vez multiplica a "p" menos 8,
y esto a su vez, es igual a 0.
Ok y lo estoy factorizando así,
porque cuando yo factorizo
una expresión cuadrática, que es igual a 0,
esto ya es mucho más fácil de trabajarlo,
estoy diciendo que o "p" más 16...
16...
esto es igual a 0 o en su dado caso...
o en su dado caso...
a este es de color amarillo déjame ponerlo...
"p" menos 8 es igual a 0, ok.
de la primera yo puedo despejar de aquí a "p"
y decir que "p"...
"p"
es igual o, espera...
déjame cambiar de color...
"p" es igual a -16, ok, o en su dado caso "p",
"p" es igual a 8,
si de aquí despejó a "p"
lo único que hice
fue igualar a estas dos a 0,
porque si tengo dos números
multiplicándose igual a 0,
ó el primero es 0,
ó el segundo es 0, ok,
y entonces ya tengo dos posibles ,resultados
o que "p" sea igual a 16
ó en su dado caso que "p" sea igual a 8,
estos dos resultados hacen
que se cumpla esta ecuación cuadrática
con la que nosotros estábamos trabajando,
esta ecuación cuadrática de aquí,
o esta ecuación cuadrática de aqu,í
y en este momento puedes decir,
oh, ya acabamos el problema,
"p" igual a -16
ó "p" igual a 8 y ya me voy...
sin embargo, ten cuidado,
vamos a revisar el problema,
para ver bien qué dice ,así que apréndete
estos dos valores y vamos para arriba,
"p" igual a -16,
"p" igual a 8,
subiendo... subiendo...
oh, espera,
esto se está haciendo más grande...
no, no, no, no, no...
lo quiero un poco más pequeño... ok,
y ahora si subimos...
entonces tengo dos posibles resultados,
o que "p" sea igual a -16,
o en su dado caso que "p" sea igual a 8.
¿con cuál de los dos nos quedamos?
Bueno,
ambos solucionan la ecuación cuadrática,
sin embargo, "p" igual a -16
no tiene sentido en el contexto del problema,
no podemos pensar que
Dominica hace -16 pizzas al día,
porque entonces
pues estaría en la bancarrota,
estaría vendiendo una cantidad negativa
y eso no tiene sentido.
Por lo tanto,
podemos eliminar esta solución que tengo aquí.
Voy a eliminar esta solución que tengo aquí
y me voy a quedar solamente con "p" igual a 8.
porque, es una cantidad positiva
y además la podemos utilizar en este contexto de pizzas.
Y "p" representaba el número de pizzas que ordenaba a diario, antes de que aumentará el precio.
Entonces antes de que aumentara el precio,
Dominica horneaba 8 pizzas,
después de que aumenta el precio,
Dominica va a hornear 8 pizzas más,
es decir,
va a hornear 8 más 8 = 16 pizzas en total
esto después de que aumente el precio
de los ingredientes por pizza,
y ya está resuelto el problema
de las pizzas de Dominica,
y tanta pizza ya me dio hambre.
Así que,
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo.